あどうもちゃろうです何から話せばいいのでしょうか
あの政宗のタイトル頃になったみなさまお気づきでしょうが
ん
ストローぐずる
買いすぎません
[音楽]
うーん
別に経済ませんで悪くはないんですけどもうちょっと両方がねぇ
もうこう連ねるストロングゼロのダブルでも全部でずっカートン買いましたと母とに
24入ってる240本ですね
んあ
だ付けず経緯を説明しましょう皆さんお酒飲みます
今はですのお酒飲まなかったですけれどもさすがに私今年27年人とのこともちょい
ありましたし一人でもたまに寝れない時とかちょっとある時にカルーこう酒飲んだり
することがたまにあるんですけどもそんな理由に飲ませていただいているのはこちらの
こちらのとかこちらのトーン0って
様子ですこれ9%であの頃強いんですけども見てください世界売上ナンバーワンの
チューハイですよギネスの世界記録に認定されている世界一のて界一のチューハイそれ
がストロングゼロなんですけども
メアの
好きなんですよね僕あの先にせず1軍ですけど僕全然お酒に弱くてあのめっちゃくちゃ
ちょうだい雑魚の量
これ1本飲んだらベロンベロンのばランボルになってちょっとテンション上がってすぐ
寝ちゃうくらい僕からするとちょうどいるようなんですけども結構僕がお気に入りの
おさげの一本だと思ってるんでしょ最近がその3ゼロか
お酒は二十歳になってからですよそれなんかニュース見て
たんすよね出すかこれニュースを見よってねストロングゼロのニュース見たいネットで
見かけたんですよ
これヤバイってみてもう検索のバーズにあるんですよこれがその30
終売潤井戸が終わるって意味なんでしょうね多分てこういうだから検索で出てくらい実
はなんか最近話題になってましてなんか
ストローんぶ0が売り
いやに収容するんじゃないかみたいなニュースとかあったかそれが見ちゃって僕
ウエストのアルコール大好きとかお酒だよっていたわけじゃないんですけども好きな
ものが買えなくなるやばいぞといっ
これ一生このストロングゼロで一発で決まる
あ
美味しくを先ほどの感じが味わえないんだったら俺結構嫌だなと思ってもう今売ってる
分ストロングゼロ
回だねしましょうと販売終了になってもいつでも飲めるようにしようということでと
こちらに5判買収になっても飲める状態に必要後ということで10カートン分
ストロングゼロのダブルでも俺が一番好きな誓わせていただいたんですけども
ああああああ
聞いて驚きなんか上調べた結果ああが違ったっぽいんですよねこちらのヤフーニュース
をご覧下さい
ストロング館終売決め出さちょパッドなおストーングっても違ったら俺もストロールで
覆うディーズのやめるんじゃないかって思って上場や外へ飛んでよく見てみたんです
けどこれ線よくよく見るとご覧くださいやすくで酔えることから人間のストロング系
チューハイ一方である
ゴールの数選手に健康問題につながる危険性を指摘する声も強くにその6県の終売を
発表したオリオン日での社長に背景を聞いた
覚え4 vh サントリーこれスムーズなに見せるかと言いますと販売終了にするのは
ストロングゼロではなく
もう結構級美尻です販売しルールの終了にするのはストロングゼロの会社サントリー
さんじゃなくてオリオンビールっていう会社の声ストロング県中3位の売るのやめます
という話だったんですよ
早とちり
ねしてくれよなぁなんてことしてくれたんだよこれどうすんだよ全部勝っ詰まったよ
あーやばいよまじでまじでまじやばい本当にやばいこそこれはまずでは皆さんのんな
ことある人ならわかると思うんですけどもうね9%500ml のかめちゃくちゃよう
ですよそれを私何
240本買ってしまったこんなの1年間でを飲んでたら毎日ベロンベロンよっている
状態でまともに働けば
生まれ当然ねーか
というちょっとニュースの隼人釣りねー
津市ストロングゼロ宮城の10本 zucca と当たってしまったという話でござい
ますヘアーミヤネだしてねでも9%んは先立って飲むと
アグコールで2から体の分解ねやっぱ
大変だと思えば体さんもお母さんも大変だけどもそうだねそれではから暗さを考えるの
も大事だけども私はとなりたいんですよ
を瀬木一体得なとは言いませんけど適度に飲む分にはいいかなって思うわけですねが俺
は全然これ1本でいいと思ってるし
これを毎日飲もうとも思ってないただチアはにしようぜに伸びないときにそこに
ストロングゼロ乗ったブルーレイもが1本あれば嬉しいなって思ってるんですけども
開けてみるとあービックリえっ
販売中出演者あるや待って待って待って
もう驚いては俺もニュース見たとき信じがたかったや本当に参ったよなぁヘアー
参ったよ
[音楽]
ブーバーこねえ美味しい
リーダーは分かるんだけど猫の尿あるというかもっと早く気付けば良かったなんで
ギネスへ記録乗ったんでしょ世界でそんな裏下山してるわけないじゃんもうこれだから
ニュースっていうのは怖いて皆向きを付けて下さい
なんか最近ねそういうなんかパッと見たらよく分かりにくいニュースって多いんですよ
ね匹居ると同じしたこれで見間違えてストロングゼロが潤の終わり
んじゃないかって思ってる人が結構いるっていうか本当に混ぜならツイッターとの女の
いろんな人がストロングゼロ
その二世のか好きな人が多いんですよ世界一なんてさん多いグッとらっぐらび
ねえ最近談がネットではいろんなニュースとかね色んな人が他の人が誘う結婚ちょっと
がこっち購入すとかあるんですけどもなんでもいいんでそこ攻めるかなってるお化けな
んですよねとって他人じゃないですか
わかるよ確かにその人前に出る仕事やっていいぞ例えばたく言われたりある程度
ねそういうのを守らなきゃいけないと思うんですけどもけどさ
家されること言って別にさあ俺たち何も猿クロエに何でしょうか攻めるかなってね面で
も見てないのにその人のことをよく知らないのに
ニュースとかそういうの信じてなんかベルベルベルベルしゃべるのは本当によくないと
思うぜ0最近あるという意味で本当はですねストロークなど好きな人多いと思うんで
プレゼント企画2週と思ったんですけどもねおさげをプレゼントにするのもちょっと
どうかなと思うんでこれは俺の周りのみんなで仲良くナム答えしますならもうさに俺の
周りでね6103常に人が3人いるからね
63回とかしようかなと思ってるんで音だけでちょっとねぇ
100200本子らも使うかなまぁホント程よくのランサーの皆さんも決して皆さん
仁王像を下げ舐めてくるわけじゃないですよは彼だねこういうのってたまにノブ本当に
引くとの会話が弾んだりするんですよ俺とが特にね人とのおしゃべりが苦手だから思っ
たほどがニータイムとかべらべらべらから出てこないんですよ
そんな時にを下げを挟むとなんかね自然としゃべるたりする
コミュニケーションのきっかけになるものでもあると思うんであまりたのではになっ
たらここはいいのかなと思ってたまでになってます
というわけである用量用法を正しく守ってスキューをしましょう
みんなお酒を飲み次注意謎
ウィッキー
[音楽]
ブーブーんっ
ん